في مشهد لطالما اعتاد عليه السوريون يصطف
الناس هنا لساعات في طوابير طويله املا في
الحصول على الخبز باحدى ضواحي العاصمه
دمشق
للساعه الساعه 7
الصبح
والله الى المسائل لا بيسكر سبعه السكان
هنا من اجل توفير متطلبات حياتهم اليوميه
هذه الحاله اليائسه التي وصلوا اليها
ادمعت عيناه
الجميع هنا لديه نفس القصه فهم يقفون في
طوابير لساعات طويله يوميا
ومن الممكن ان لا يتمكن الجميع من الحصول
على الخبز بينما يبلغ سعر الواحده خمسه
عشر ليره سوريه اما البديل الوحيد لهؤلاء
الناس وشرائه من السوق السوداء بعشره
اضعاف في هذا المبلغ وهذا امر من الصعب
تحمله
وبالتوازي مع ازمه طوابير الخمس الطويله
تعاني دمشق من نقص حاد في الوقود ايضا ففي
كثير من الاحيان تتوقف الشاحنات التي تنقل
مكونات الخبز عن السير بسبب نقص الوقود
ويستضيف سيقول السيارات ب طوابير طويله
ايضا للحصول على البنزين في عدد قليل من
المحطات التي يتوفر بها
ونظرا للاعداد الضخمه من النازحين
والسياحه شبه المعدومه يحل هذا الصراع
اقتصاد البلد بشكل كبير وفي المدينه
التاريخيه تنتشر محلات النحاس وورش العمل
التقليديه فقد عملت عائله غالبيه في صياغه
الادوات النحاسيه على مدى اجيال ولكن مع
تزايد حده العنف يبدو ان كل شيء قد تغيرت
اثرت علينا هو مساله يعني وجود المواد
اما تاثير ما في التاثير يعني
وجود الوادي
وعلى مر مئات السنين نجده حرفه النحاس
وغيرها من الحركه التجاريه من ويلات الحرب
التي ضربت دمشق ورغم المخاوف جراء الوضع
الراهن الذي يعصف بالبلاد يواصل هؤلاء
الحرفيون عملهم